.
* Mystische, glockige Klänge *
Die psychiatrische Klinik Bellelay
liegt dort,
wo man die psychisch Erkrankten
lange haben wollte: am Ende der Welt.
Ich habe meine Jugend
im Kanton Jura verbracht.
Sobald wir uns
etwas ausserhalb der Norm benahmen,
hiess es: "Du endest noch
bei den Irren in Bellelay".
Ursprünglich war Bellelay
im Berner Jura ein Kloster.
Nachdem die Abtei
geschlossen worden war,
fanden die Menschen hier
medizinische Hilfe.
Seit 130 Jahren ist Bellelay
eine psychiatrische Klinik.
Es gibt den Geist von Bellelay.
Heute ist es für viele Patienten
ein guter Geist.
Es ist das zweite Daheim,
wenn es nicht mehr geht,
würde ich sagen.
* Mystische, glockige Klänge *
Damit ist nun Schluss.
Die Umzugsautos stehen bereit.
Gegen den Willen der Mehrheit
der Patient/-innen und des Personals
wird die psychiatrische Klinik
ins Spital von Moutier integriert.
Zu abgelegen
und kaum wirtschaftlich zu betreiben
sei Bellelay, sagen die Behörden.
(Frau) Morgens,
sobald man den Dienst beginnt,
spürt man schon, ob die Stimmung
ruhig oder angespannt ist.
Werden Türen zugeschlagen?
Schreien Patientinnen?
Oder schlafen noch alle
und es ist ruhig?
Wir hören, wie Essenswagen ankommen,
ein Alarm, der schrillt,
weil jemand aggressiv ist.
* Mystische, glockige Klänge *
Unsere Schritte im Gang.
All diese Geräusche bedeuten Alltag.
Einen Klinikalltag wie in Bellelay
wird es so
wohl bald nicht mehr geben.
Der Kostendruck ist zu hoch geworden.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
An meinem ersten Arbeitstag,
als ich meinen Ausbildner hier traf,
brach in Tränen aus,
ich sagte: "Ich kann das nicht."
"Ich kann nicht hierbleiben.
Ich habe Angst."
Heute weiss ich,
dass es Einbildung war,
aber damals
habe ich es sehr stark empfunden.
"Ich werde vielleicht geschlagen
oder angegriffen", dachte ich.
Ich wollte nicht hier sein.
Es kam anders.
Céline Bärfuss
arbeitet seit zehn Jahren hier
und ist stellvertretende Pflegechefin
in Bellelay.
Ja,
hier geht es oft drunter und drüber.
Das liebe ich an meiner Arbeit.
Ich habe es gerne, wenn etwas läuft,
und ertrage es schlecht,
wenn Dinge verschleppt werden
oder ich im Büro rumsitzen muss.
Ich bin ein Bewegungsmensch
und gerne bei den Patienten.
So bin ich.
Sonst ist es mir langweilig.
Hier in die Abteilung 1
kommen Patientinnen,
die sich
in einer akuten Krise befinden.
Diese junge Frau leidet unter
einer psychischen Dekompensation,
umgangssprachlich:
Nervenzusammenbruch.
Céline und ihr Team
versuchen sie zu beruhigen.
Voilà!
- Hoppla.
Wenn eine Person ankommt,
die ruhig ist,
gehe ich allein zu ihr
und stelle mich vor.
Ich spreche mit ruhiger Stimme
und versuche
keine abrupten Bewegungen zu machen.
* Erregte Äusserungen *
Anders ist es, wenn ein Patient
in Aufruhr ist und Angst hat.
Dann ist es viel schwieriger, weil
wir dann mehrere Pflegende sind.
Das beruhigt vielleicht uns,
aber nicht unbedingt den Patienten.
Wir versuchen ruhig zu sprechen,
aber manchmal
funktioniert es trotzdem nicht.
Wir sind ein Notfalldienst,
eine Krisenintervention.
Man braucht schon etwas
Lebenserfahrung und Bodenhaftung,
um die Situationen hier aufzufangen.
Es gibt viel Leid
und auch viel Gewalt,
viele schwierige Momente.
Es ist ein Ort,
an dem sich die Situation
extrem schnell ändern kann.
Es kann ruhig sein
und eine Viertelstunde später
fliegt einem alles um die Ohren.
Es ist fast wie ein Pulverfass.
Der Chefpfleger der Abteilung
ist erfahren und schon lange hier.
Seine Motivation
hat über die Jahre nicht abgenommen.
Das hier
ist ein grosser Teil meines Lebens.
Seit 1993
gehe ich in diesem Haus ein und aus.
Für das Leiden der Menschen
Lösungen zu finden,
Hilfe zu organisieren,
das ist meine berufliche Passion.
Hier müssen wir eine Lösung finden.
Es ist ein schwieriger Entzug.
Wir sind nun
auf 4 x 50 mg Seresta gegangen.
Sie hat fast nicht geschlafen,
nur etwa 3 Std.
Können wir nicht etwas versuchen
bez. diesem Isolationszimmer?
Ich würde sagen,
wir lockern von Zeit zu Zeit,
aber wir vereinbaren
einen klaren Rahmen mit ihm.
Und wenn er uns
die WC-Schüssel kaputtmacht,
macht er sie halt kaputt.
Ich habe Angst, dass wir sonst
antitherapeutisch werden.
Wenn es nicht geht, streichen wir
die Lockerungen wieder.
Behandelt werden hier u.a.
bipolare Störungen, Schizophrenie,
schwere Depressionen, Burn-outs.
Neben dem Notfall
gibt es eine Abteilung,
die auf ältere Personen mit psy-
chischen Problemen spezialisiert ist,
und eine, die sich um Personen
mit psychischen Erkrankungen kümmert,
deren Zustand stabil ist.
Wie oft
bist du schon hierhergekommen?
Ähm ...
Etwa zehnmal, glaube ich.
Nach einer Weile
funktionieren meine Medikamente
jeweils nicht mehr richtig
und dann bin ich wieder hier.
Liona ist 26 und hat eine lange
Geschichte mit der Klinik Bellelay.
Bellelay
ist für mich manchmal ein Spital.
Manchmal ein Ort,
um zur Ruhe zu kommen.
Je nachdem, in welcher Abteilung
ich platziert werde.
Moi, je suis le roi de Bienne.
Ich bin völlig zusammengebrochen.
Es war hart.
Ich musste auch in die Isolation.
Ich habe alle Stufen der Psychiatrie
durchgemacht.
Liona kennt die Einsamkeit
des Isolationszimmers.
Wobei die Pflegenden
diese Bezeichnung nicht mögen.
Dieses Zimmer
ist ein Raum für die Intensivpflege.
Hierher verlegen wir Patienten,
die für sich selbst oder für andere
eine Gefahr darstellen.
Es wird sehr genau abgewogen, ob
jemand ins Isolationszimmer kommt.
Man weiss ja,
dass man jemandem die Freiheit nimmt
und dass die Türe
von aussen geschlossen wird.
Es ist nie einfach,
dort eingeschlossen zu sein.
In diesem Zimmer
gibt es einfach nichts.
* Mystische, glockige Klänge *
Die Patienten
drücken ihre Gefühle oft aus,
indem sie auf die Mauern schreiben.
Sie sind hier wirklich allein.
(Liona) Man bringt mir dort
einzig das Essen und einen Löffel.
Ich habe keine Brille,
keine Hausschuhe, keine Uhr.
In der Isolation ist man,
wenn es wirklich nicht mehr geht.
In solchen Momenten
ist man von der realen Welt
sowieso völlig abgeschnitten.
Man dreht sich im Kreis,
man weiss nie, wie viel Uhr es ist.
Es ist ziemlich mühsam.
Auf der anderen Seite
gibt es einem die Zeit,
über sich selbst nachzudenken.
Über alles, was nicht gut läuft.
Als Bastien 29 Jahre alt war, wurde
er das erste Mal hier hospitalisiert.
Doch er kannte Bellelay schon zuvor.
In meiner beruflichen Laufbahn,
in der so ziemlich alles schieflief,
wollte ich auch einmal
Pfleger werden.
Ich habe hier
mein Praktikum gemacht,
das aber nicht gut verlaufen ist.
Ich hatte also keine Lust,
nach Bellelay zurückzukommen.
* Schrille Klänge *
Ich bin depressiv.
Da sind Momente grosser Einsamkeit.
Man grübelt den ganzen Tag lang
an etwas herum, man isoliert sich,
hat dunkle Gedanken,
suizidale Gedanken.
Und im schlimmsten Fall
schreitet man zur Tat.
Ich bin freiwillig hergekommen.
Ich weiss, wieso ich hier bin:
um aus der Krise zu finden.
Ich brauche Bellelay.
Es gibt einige,
die unfreiwillig hier sind.
Für sie ist es schwieriger.
Sie verstehen nicht,
wieso sie hier sind, und wollen weg.
Einige kommen aus freiem Willen.
Aber viele sind hier in einer sog.
fürsorgerischen Unterbringung
und wurden gegen ihren Willen
eingewiesen.
Viele wollen weg.
Wie dieser junge Mann,
der regelmässig in Bellelay ist.
Er riss aus und landete
in einer psychiatrischen Einrichtung
in Frankreich -
deshalb die weissen Kleider.
Bist du gut gereist?
Ja, es war cool.
Wir hörten Rock 'n' Roll.
Haben sie dir etwas gespritzt?
Ja, sie haben mir
Neuroleptika gespritzt.
Das hat mich stabilisiert.
Ich hoffe nur,
dass ihr mich nicht einsperrt.
Das wäre cool.
Nur deine Sachen, wie immer.
Sind deine Taschen leer?
Gehen wir.
Die Pflegenden begleiten
und durchsuchen den jungen Mann,
machen eine Urinprobe.
Die Abläufe sind klar festgelegt.
Auch Zuhören ist wichtig,
denn die Patienten
sind durch ihre Krankheit
oft geschwächt und ängstlich.
Ich habe
keinen einzigen Joint geraucht.
Nur in Annemasse, danach nicht mehr.
Ich habe schon Leute ankommen sehen,
die sehr, sehr grosse Angst hatten.
Wir schliessen zwar die Türen ab und
nehmen Patienten die Freiheit ...
(Patient) Ich bin wieder
auf dem Boden der Realität gelandet.
(Olivier) ... aber der Sinn
ist nicht, abzuschliessen,
um jemanden zu strafen
oder zu vergessen.
Nein, hinter den verschlossenen
Türen ist die Pflege sehr intensiv,
folgt klaren Abläufen
und ist sehr präzis.
Doch viele Menschen verbinden
die Pflege in der Psychiatrie
mit Zwangsmassnahmen.
Die Leute haben eine falsche
Vorstellung davon, was wir machen.
Sie denken ans Einsperren,
an Spritzen.
Sie denken, wir seien irgendwie
"Wachen" oder Irrenaufseher.
Es ist schade, dass man
dieses Bild der Psychiatrie hat.
Denn unser Beruf besteht nicht
darin, die Leute einzuschliessen.
Unsere Arbeit ist nicht fertig,
wenn wir jemanden aufgenommen haben,
dem es nicht gut geht.
Wir begleiten die Personen,
versuchen zu verstehen,
eine Beziehung aufzubauen,
zu erklären
und die Einsicht in eine Krankheit
oder nötige Behandlung zu fördern.
Ich möchte gerne Medikamente
gegen Durchfall. Wegen des Lithiums.
Ja, das kann sein,
das ist eine der Nebenwirkungen.
Haben Sie die Ärzte informiert?
Oder sollen wir das machen?
Sie wissen es.
Ungerecht und hartherzig -
das Image der Psychiatrie
kommt nicht von ungefähr.
* Düstere Klänge *
Bis Ende der 70er-Jahre
waren die Methoden in Bellelay
ganz anders als heute.
Roland Monnat kam 1971
als Pfleger in die Klinik.
Er erinnert sich.
Die Psychiatrie war von der
Gesellschaft völlig abgeschottet.
Es gab keine Durchmischung.
Es gab zwar eine Pflege -
sie war auch nicht so schlecht -,
aber man hatte klare Vorstellungen
über psychische Erkrankungen.
Das war etwas, was man abschirmen
und wegschliessen musste.
Es war noch die Psychiatrie
des 20. Jh.
Es hatte etwas Gefängnishaftes.
Das Einsperren führte zu Unruhe
und zu einer inneren Isolation.
Auch bei den Pflegenden.
* Verstummende mystische Klänge *
In den 80er-Jahren
kam Bewegung in die Psychiatrie -
auch in Bellelay.
Vieles änderte sich
unter dem Einfluss
des fortschrittlichen Psychiaters
Dr. Van.
Die Gesellschaft
hat in ihrer Grausamkeit
nur eine Lösung gefunden
für die psychisch Kranken:
sie wegzusperren.
Damit beruhigte man sich selbst
im Sinne von:
"Wir sind gesund
und die sind verrückt."
Nun haben wir es 20 Jahre lang
anders gemacht.
Wir haben die Türen der Klinik
geöffnet.
Und ich glaube nicht,
dass es dem Berner Jura
deswegen schlechter geht.
Es gab diese schnelle,
sehr schnelle Öffnung.
Man hat die Abteilungen geöffnet,
es gab eine ganz neue Sicht
auf psychische Erkrankungen.
Diese Klinik wurde bekannt dafür.
So haben wir z.B. einen Tag
der offenen Tür eingeführt.
Die Leute kamen und waren erstaunt,
als sie sahen, wie es hier läuft.
Hier läuft Menschliches,
nichts anderes.
Trotz dieser Öffnung
blieb der Name Bellelay für viele
mit den alten Bildern der Psychiatrie
verknüpft.
Ich denke, Bellelay haftet immer
noch etwas von einer Anstalt an.
Auch wenn sich viel geändert hat
in den Köpfen der Menschen -
das Bild der Anstalt bleibt.
Darum bleibt es für viele schwierig,
hierherzukommen.
Bellelay ist mit negativen Bildern
aus der Vergangenheit konnotiert.
Das sieht man bei gewissen Familien.
Sie leiden furchtbar
unter dem Umstand,
dass jemand aus der Familie -
eine Tochter, ein Sohn -
nach Bellelay kommen muss.
Mehr noch als die Mitarbeitenden
sind es die Patient/-innen,
die unter den alten Geschichten
aus der Psychiatrie leiden.
Viele der Patienten,
die ich hier kenne,
wurden stigmatisiert,
weil sie krank sind.
Ich finde das abscheulich.
Man sucht sich das doch nicht aus.
Aber unsere Krankheiten
scheinen anderen Angst zu machen.
Doch wir sind keine Monster.
Wir können normal
vor eine Kamera treten.
Wir sind nicht ansteckend.
Man hat mir schon gesagt:
"Wenn ich von deiner Krankheit
gewusst hätte,
hätte ich dich nicht
mit den Kindern spielen lassen."
Das schmerzt wirklich.
Aber es zeigt v.a.,
wie wenig die Menschen
über psychische Krankheiten wissen.
Und wie wenig sie überlegen, was
solche Bemerkungen auslösen können.
Wenn man mit den Menschen über
psychische Erkrankungen spricht,
also über Depressionen
oder gewisse andere Diagnosen,
so spürt man ihre Angst davor.
Auch bei sich selbst
findet man diese Angst.
Es gibt eine unbewusste
Identifikation der Menschen damit.
Im Sinne von: "Auch mich
könnte es eines Tages treffen."
"Auch mir könnte es schlecht gehen."
"Ich könnte die Kontrolle verlieren,
könnte zusammenbrechen."
Die Patientinnen der Psychiatrie
spiegeln diese Angst.
Er fühlt sich nicht bereit dazu,
nach Hause zu gehen.
Er will mit uns nach Moutier kommen.
Mir scheint,
es gehe ihm etwas besser.
Aber wir müssen noch schauen,
wie das Antipsychotikum wirkt.
Er will erst etwas,
wenn es ihm wieder gut geht.
Wir müssen ihm aufzeigen,
dass er einfach machen muss
und es so besser wird.
Er wartet v.a. darauf,
dass seine Freundin zurückkommt.
Er sagt, wenn er heimgehen müsse,
konsumiere er wieder.
Aber er kann ja nicht
ewig hier warten,
bis seine Freundin zurückkommt.
Wir müssen eine neue Freundin
für ihn finden.
Wir helfen den Patienten,
eine andere Perspektive einzunehmen.
Das macht diesen Beruf so schön.
Dabei zu helfen, etwas zu verändern,
z.B. ein Wohnheim zu finden.
Sie ist gekommen,
um sich bei uns zu bedanken.
Auch wenn es immer noch
viele Vorurteile gibt,
sind psychische Erkrankungen
heute kein endgültiges Urteil mehr.
Die Patient/-innen
werden therapeutisch begleitet.
Wie hier in der Abteilung 2.
In diese Abteilung kommt,
wer die akute Krise überwunden hat.
Hier ist alles etwas lockerer.
Die Patienten werden begleitet,
man hört ihnen zu.
Diese Art Psychiatrie mag ich -
die Therapie, die Gespräche,
die professionellen
und die informellen.
Das mag ich sehr.
* Mystische, schwebende Klänge *
Auf dem Stock der Abteilung 2
liegt auch das Beschäftigungsatelier.
Für die Patient/-innen
ein Ort zum Durchatmen
und um auf andere Ideen zu kommen.
* Helle Klänge *
Hier könnten alle sich selbst sein.
Es werde nicht geurteilt und
es würden keine Diagnosen gestellt,
das sagen uns die Patientinnen oft.
Sie können sich hier gehen lassen.
Je le ramollis un tout petit peu.
Pour l'instant, vous pouvez ...
Und sie fühlten sich hier nicht
wie in einem Spital.
Es sei wie eine Insel.
* Helle Klänge *
(Liona) Schon beim ersten Aufenthalt
habe ich sofort gesagt,
dass ich ins Atelier will.
Sie waren einverstanden.
Ich habe mich sofort wohlgefühlt,
nicht anders.
Hier kann ich in Frieden sein
mit mir selbst.
Voilà! Encore un café ici.
Ich hatte auch sofort
ein gutes Verhältnis
zu den Mitarbeiterinnen.
Es tut gut,
mit ihnen zu lachen und zu weinen.
Das geht nicht unbedingt
mit einer Pflegerin oder einem Arzt.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Merci, c'est gentil.
- Merci beaucoup.
Tout ce qu'on a à vous offrir,
c'est de l'eau.
(Bastien) Das hier
ist kein Ferienaufenthalt,
auch wenn es vielleicht
so aussehen mag.
Aber wir sind hier,
um gesund zu werden.
Es ist das Gegenteil von Ferien.
Alle haben irgendein Problem
und arbeiten daran.
Gesund zu werden
ist nicht nur ein Job -
es ist ein ganzes Unterfangen.
Das Leben als Patient oder Patientin
ist nicht einfach.
Auch wenn man leidet,
gilt es, voranzugehen
und die therapeutischen Ziele
weiterzuverfolgen.
Nach mehreren Wochen
in der Krisenintervention
wurde Bastien
in die Abteilung 2 verlegt.
Mit seiner Sozialarbeiterin
bereitet er seinen Austritt vor.
Wie geht es?
Gut, gut.
Haben Sie am Wochenende
Ihre Eltern gesehen?- Ja.
Dann konnten Sie Ihrer Mutter sagen,
dass Sie am Donnerstag die
neue Wohnung besichtigen könnten?
So ist es.
Kann Ihre Mutter Sie abholen?
Sie holt mich
und bringt mich wieder zurück.
Dann ist das geregelt.
Der Arzt weiss auch Bescheid.
Er hat die Absenz
am Donnerstagnachmittag bewilligt.
Mein Ziel ist es,
wieder fit zu werden.
Zu schwimmen, Sport zu treiben,
um mich wieder besser zu fühlen
in meinem Körper.
Wegen der Medikamente
habe ich stark zugenommen.
Ich möchte mich wieder
um mich kümmern.
Vielleicht kann ich auch
in einer geschützten Werkstatt
etwas arbeiten.
Damit ich beschäftigt bin.
Ziele zu haben ist hilfreich.
Doch die Klinik zu verlassen
und nach Hause zu gehen,
bleibt eine Herausforderung -
auch für Viviane.
Sie packt ihre Koffer,
nachdem sie mehrere Wochen
in der Klinik verbracht hat.
Meine Mutter ist gestorben,
meine Schwägerin ist gestorben.
Es kam viel zusammen, auch
familiäre Probleme, viel Stress.
Am Ende hatte ich eine Art Burn-out.
Wieder nach Hause zu gehen,
ist hart.
Man schliesst die Menschen hier ins
Herz, weil alle ein Leiden haben.
Jeder hat irgendein Problem.
So ist es einfach,
Kontakt zu finden.
Sogar wenn man jemanden
erst zwei Tage kennt,
versteht man sich gut,
weil man das Gleiche erlebt hat.
Mein Sohn.
Das Foto kommt zurück
ins Portemonnaie.
Ich wollte es nahe bei mir haben.
Cette fois-ci, c'est bon.
Je viens chercher mes affaires.
Es ist schwierig, heimzugehen,
allen Adieu zu sagen.
Die Patientinnen sind auch
füreinander eine grosse Hilfe.
Nicht nur die Ärzte
und die Pflegenden.
Unter den Patienten
wird viel diskutiert,
man tauscht sich aus.
Manchmal weint jemand,
dann spricht man über das Problem.
Man hilft sich gegenseitig.
Also, danke für alles.
Passen Sie auf sich auf.
- Oui, vous aussi.
Bis bald vielleicht.
- Ja, aber anderswo.
Alles Gute.
Au revoir, tout de bon!
In den kleinen Dörfern gibt es
vielleicht Menschen, die denken,
Bellelay sei für die Verrückten,
ein Irrenhaus.
Aber es ist kein Ort für Verrückte.
Die Menschen hier sind sensible
Menschen, die Probleme haben.
Wunderbare, wertvolle Menschen
mit einem grossen Herz.
Man hat mir schon gesagt,
ich sei eine Irre.
Weil ich depressiv bin
und in Bellelay war.
Aber wir sind nicht verrückt.
Wir haben nur mehr Mühe,
unsere Gefühle zu regulieren.
Nathalie ist für einen Besuch
zurückgekommen.
Erst vor Kurzem wurde sie
nach einem Monat Aufenthalt
aus Bellelay entlassen.
Bonjour!
Es ist besser, hierherzukommen
und nicht Patientin zu sein.
Ja, besuchen ist besser!
Mais le coin
est toujours autant sympa.
Können wir etwas für dich tun?
Hättet ihr nicht ein Plätzchen
für zwei, drei Tage?
Dein damaliges Zimmer
ist nicht besetzt.
Du hattest Glück
mit deinen Zimmernachbarinnen.
Ja, ich bin draussen
mit allen in Kontakt geblieben.
Ja, die Zweierzimmer
ermöglichen Solidarität.
Aber es kann auch Ärger geben.
- Ja, das auch.
Es ist schon so,
dass Bellelay für mich ein Ort ist,
an dem ich mich
wieder einmitten kann und auftanke.
Hier kann man alles vergessen,
alle Probleme.
Es gibt keine Stadt, es gibt
einfach nichts ausser Wiesen.
Es ist der ideale Ort,
wenn alles zu viel wird
und man nicht mehr zurechtkommt.
Ich war eigentlich nicht bereit,
zu gehen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
nicht genug Kraft zu haben.
Ich habe eine Sozialphobie
und sobald es zu viele Menschen hat,
geht es nicht mehr.
Aber ja, ich schlage mich durch.
Im Moment geht es.
* Helle, schwebende Klänge *
Bellelay ist ein Asyl,
ein geschützter Ort auf Zeit.
Das Wort Asyl bedeutet,
dass man an einem sicheren Ort ist.
Hier bedeutet es auch, dass man
in diesem geschützten Rahmen
wieder lernt,
soziale Kontakte aufzubauen.
Es ist sehr oft so,
dass man die Leute ermuntern muss,
nach Hause zu gehen.
Man musste sogar schon
die Polizei rufen,
um eine Person
nach Hause zu bringen.
Alle brauchen soziale Kontakte.
Diese kann man hier gut aufbauen.
Trotzdem kommt der Moment,
an dem man gehen muss.
Heute dauert ein Aufenthalt
in Bellelay
durchschnittlich drei Wochen.
Früher aber
war die Klinik ein Ort fürs Leben.
Schau, das ist witzig.
Man weiss gar nicht,
wer Patientin und wer Pfleger ist.
Sie spielen wohl Schach.
In Bellelay stecken
120 Jahre Psychiatriegeschichte.
Die Geschichte wird weitergegeben
an jede neue Generation Pflegende.
Jeder von uns ist ein kleines Stück
dieser Geschichte,
des grossen Ganzen.
Was für mich heraussticht,
sind die starken Werte.
Menschenwürde,
Sicherheit, Authentizität.
Es wurde hier ein Arbeitsort
mit einer Art Mikrogesellschaft
geschaffen.
Ein Ort, an dem sich die Patienten
in Sicherheit fühlen
und ihr Leiden leben können.
* Mystische, glockige Klänge *
Diesen geschützten Rahmen
wird auch Bastien bald verlassen.
Also, am 28. gehe ich.
Ich habe darum gebeten,
ich will vorwärtsmachen.
Du lässt mich allein?
- Ja.
Wie ein totaler Feigling.
Nein, nein.
Es ist gut, dass du gehst. Besser.
Bastien habe ich ein bisschen
unter meine Fittiche genommen.
Am Anfang war es sehr hart für ihn.
Es gab sehr schwierige Momente,
da konnte ich auch nichts machen.
Aber ich habe den Pflegenden
Bonbons mitgegeben
mit Botschaften an ihn,
um ihm Mut zu machen.
Wenn er mich sah,
war er richtig glücklich.
Umarmungen und so und Dankeschöns,
obwohl er eigentlich
Sugus gar nicht mag.
Es tut mir gut,
wenn ich Menschen lächeln sehe.
* Düstere, flirrende Klänge *
Die Nacht erinnert daran,
dass vieles in Bellelay fragil ist.
Für die Pfleger Azmir und Corentin
ist es die Zeit,
in der sie einige Patienten
in ihre Zimmer zurückbringen.
Ein schwieriger Moment.
Das Durchsuchen der Patienten
und der Zimmer,
eine informelle Befragung,
geführt mit sanfter Stimme.
Es wird alles unternommen,
um ein Unglück zu verhindern.
Hattest du einen guten Tag?
Nein.
- Warum?
Ich habe Angst vor meiner Familie.
Wenn du Angst hast,
können wir dir Medikamente geben,
dich etwas beruhigen.
Ist das in Ordnung?
- Ja.
Nun ist es Zeit,
ins Zimmer zu gehen.
Ihr nehmt es genau.
- Ja.
Schönen Abend.
Meistens kommen die Ängste
am Abend zurück oder werden stärker.
Es ist wie ein kleiner Tod.
Oft sind es schwierige Momente
für die Patient/-innen.
Du bist alleine, die Gesellschaft
der anderen ist weg.
Man ist
auf sich selbst zurückgeworfen,
auf seine Gefühle,
seine Sorgen, das Leiden.
Als Nachtwache erlebt man sehr
persönliche Momente, sehr viel Nähe.
In meinen Augen
ist die Nacht eine sehr gute Schule,
denn man ist gezwungen, sich auf all
seine Fähigkeiten und Erfahrungen,
auf alle Zusammenhänge zu besinnen,
um den inneren Konflikt
zu bewältigen.
Die Nacht
ist eine hervorragende Schule.
* Flirrende Klänge *
* Düstere Musik setzt ein. *
* Gespenstische Klänge *
Mit dem Tagesanbruch
weichen die Abgründe der Nacht.
Hoffnung und Aufbruchstimmung
nehmen Oberhand.
* Schnelles Piepen *
Je n'ai pas compris.
* Gespenstische Klänge *
Renaud beginnt den Tag mit neuem Mut.
Ich war am Boden des Abgrunds,
als ich vor zweieinhalb Wochen
hier ankam.
Dann musste ich den Hang
wieder hinaufsteigen.
Und v.a.
meine Lebensfreude wieder finden,
die ich vollkommen verloren hatte.
Nun geht es besser.
V.a. wegen etwas,
das man Liebe nennt.
Ich habe hier jemanden getroffen.
Niemals hätte ich daran gedacht,
dass ich in Bellelay
Liebe finden würde.
Deswegen kommt man ja nicht hierher.
Und an Liebe auf den ersten Blick
habe ich sowieso nicht geglaubt
und auch nicht daran, dass ich mich
so schnell wieder verlieben könnte.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Bellelay kann viele Ängste auslösen.
Aber die Klinik steht auch am Anfang
einiger schöner Geschichten.
Gut geschlafen?
Geht es oder brauchst du Hilfe?
Johanna, genannt Jojo,
hat eine Autismus-Spektrum-Störung.
Sie ist
auf der Abteilung 2 untergebracht.
Jojo ist
seit eineinhalb Jahren in Bellelay.
Es liess sich
kein Heim für sie finden.
So ist Bellelay ihr Daheim geworden.
Ein Beispiel für die
menschliche Haltung dieser Klinik.
Sie ist rührend.
Ich glaube, es gibt niemanden hier,
der ihren Namen nicht kennt.
Und ich glaube, es gibt niemanden,
der sie nicht liebt.
Sie hat dieses Talent,
geliebt zu werden.
Mein Herz schmilzt bei ihr.
Wenn sie kommt und meine Hand nimmt
und mich bittet,
Zeit mit ihr zu verbringen.
Tu veux que je t'aide
à couper les oefs?
Pas tout ça dans la bouche,
attends.
On a le temps.
Es ist eine komplexe Situation
mit Jojo.
Sie braucht eine sehr spezifische
und intensive Betreuung.
Es ist kaum möglich, einen Ort
hier in der Gegend zu finden,
der diese Bedürfnisse abdeckt.
So sind wir eingesprungen.
Als Lebensort.
Doch eigentlich sollte es einen
solchen Ort auch ausserhalb geben.
Ich höre zu.
* Sie spricht unverständlich. *
Du bist die Königin deines Körpers.
Aber wenn es blutet,
was machst du dann?
J'arrête.
- Genau!
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Kuss.
Für mich auch?
Bis morgen, Süsse.
Lidia arbeitet seit 20 Jahren
in Bellelay.
Sie hat fast mütterliche Gefühle
für die Patient/-innen.
Es stimmt, einige sind für mich
wie meine Kinder.
Sie kommen und sagen:
"Oh, Mama, wie geht es dir?"
Ja, ich verbringe manchmal
etwas Zeit mit ihnen, lache, spiele.
Es gab welche, die fragten mich, ob
sie mir ein Küsschen geben dürften.
Ich habe gesagt: "Ja, klar!"
Das hat sie gefreut und mich hat es
gefreut, dass es sie gefreut hat.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass sie etwas Zuneigung brauchen,
dass sie davon zu wenig haben.
Und diese Dinge sind ja gratis.
Ich habe in einer Fabrik gearbeitet
und in der Gastronomie,
aber hier habe ich
meinen Platz gefunden.
Hier habe ich viel gelernt.
Für mein Leben, meine ich.
Früher musste ich mir immer
einen Tritt in den Hintern geben,
um zur Arbeit zu gehen.
Wenn es nun Probleme gibt, urteile
ich nicht mehr, auch nicht draussen.
Nicht urteilen,
einfach nur Menschlichkeit zeigen.
Diese Mission wird die Belegschaft
bald anderswo umsetzen.
Für den Umzug nach Moutier
spreche die zentralere Lage
und die Entstigmatisierung
psychischer Krankheiten,
sagen die Befürworter.
Als ich das erste Mal
nach Bellelay kam,
hat mich dieser Ort
wirklich berührt.
Gleichzeitig habe ich mich gefragt,
ob es richtig ist,
hier Leute zu pflegen.
Es ist ein wunderschöner Ort,
aber ich habe den Eindruck,
dass es kein adäquater Platz ist,
um Leute zu pflegen.
Das ist ein wunderschöner Ort
voller Geschichte,
umgeben von Wiesen und Wäldern.
Der Bus fährt zwei- bis dreimal
pro Tag hin und zurück.
Aber ist es nicht besser,
mit den Patient/-innen
in der Realität zu arbeiten?
Im echten Leben?
Indem wir nach Moutier gehen,
zeigen wir doch auch,
dass die psychische Gesundheit nicht
nur ein paar wenige etwas angeht.
Sie muss uns alle interessieren.
Hinter dem Umzug stecken aber auch
finanzielle Überlegungen.
Die Klinik machte jahrelang Defizite.
Das wollte der Kanton
nicht mehr tragen.
Doch die meisten hier
sind gegen den Umzug.
(Céline) Die Umgebung hier
ist unser Werkzeug.
Die Gärten, die Natur.
Wenn man mit jemandem
etwas besprechen will
und ein Sitzungszimmer
zu formell scheint,
geht man nach draussen.
Das kreiert
eine andere Art von Beziehung.
Gerade mit Patientinnen
in akuten Krisen
führt Céline oft draussen Gespräche.
Mit dem unkontrollierten Essen
an sich konnte ich leben.
Es war mehr das Danach,
wenn ich mir eingestehen musste,
dass das einfach nicht normal ist.
(Céline) Dann bedeutet das wohl,
dass es Gründe gibt,
weshalb du hier bist.
(Patrick) Bellelay
ist eine eigene Welt in der Welt.
Man ist etwas isoliert.
Das erlaubt den Menschen,
sich zurückzuziehen
von all den externen Stimuli,
die oft mit ein Grund sind
für einen Zusammenbruch.
Hier gibt es keine Blicke
von anderen Leuten.
Man kann einfach man selbst sein.
Und diese Landschaft.
Der Ort gibt einem Ruhe.
Dieses Gebäude, die Korridore,
die Grosszügigkeit der Räume.
Man kann sich hier bewegen,
ist nicht eingeengt.
Das ist natürlich
ein grossartiges Arbeitsinstrument.
Oder war es - leider.
Schon morgen ist hier Schluss.
Patrick und Céline
versuchen in Gesprächen
die Stimmung zu erfassen.
Liona hängt sehr an diesem Ort.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Sind Sie gestresst oder ängstlich?
Oder freuen Sie sich?
Wie erleben Sie das alles?
(Frau) Nach Moutier zu ziehen,
beunruhigt mich schon.
Gibt es etwas,
das Ihnen helfen könnte?
Oder gibt es nichts, das hilft?
Das ist ja auch möglich.
Sie kommen hierher
und sind nicht stabil.
Und nun bringt man sie zusätzlich
in eine Situation,
die auch völlig instabil ist.
Mit Teams, die überall herumrennen,
Orte, die sie nicht kennen.
Viele sind mit Bellelay
sehr verbunden,
weil sie mehrmals hierherkamen.
Die Situation
ist für sie sehr beängstigend.
Wie wird es in Moutier sein?
Wird es gut sein oder nicht?
Wir versuchen
die Menschen zu stabilisieren.
Dieser Umzug bringt alles mit sich,
was in der Psychiatrie
nicht sein darf:
eine instabile Situation,
die destabilisiert.
Ja, das hat schon
Stress und Angst erzeugt.
Ich habe mir eine kleine Strategie
überlegt für dich.
Morgen gebe ich dir
den Kittel einer Pflegerin.
Den magst du doch so gerne.
Und dann machen wir einen
Rollentausch und du wirst Pflegerin.
Ja.
Dann machen wir das morgen?
Cool! Merci.
- Okay.
Ich hoffe, dass ich nächstes Jahr
meine Aufnahmeprüfungen
für die Universität machen kann.
Ich möchte
einen Bachelor in Psychiatrie machen
und dann eine Ausbildung
als Tiertherapeutin.
Oder
in einer psychiatrischen Einrichtung
als Peer-Therapeutin arbeiten.
Das wird lange dauern
und nicht einfach sein,
aber ich glaube, mit der Hilfe
meines Umfelds kann ich es schaffen.
* Sanfte, perlende Musik *
... mais une dizaine, ça suffit.
Diese Mauern haben alles gehört
und alles gesehen.
Dramatische Szenen, lautes Lachen,
Umarmungen, Aufmunterungen.
Ja, es ist hart, dass wir nun
die Kisten packen müssen.
Es ist wirklich nicht einfach.
Aber zu wissen, dass das ganze Team
mitkommt, ist eine Erleichterung.
Wenn man hier 15, 16 Jahre war
oder wie Patrick noch länger,
ist es anders,
als wenn man gerade angefangen hat.
Wir müssen wohl
Trauerarbeit leisten.
Es ist eine Trauer.
Voilà.
Letzte Mahlzeit in Bellelay,
letztes Eintauchen in Erinnerungen.
In einigen Stunden
werden alle in Moutier sein.
* Schwebende, melancholische Musik *
Ich schäme mich nicht,
in Bellelay gewesen zu sein.
zu sagen, dass ich krank bin.
Ich fand es wichtig,
in diesem Film zu sprechen -
über Bellelay und das Umfeld hier.
Damit die Leute verstehen, dass dies
kein furchtbarer, kalter Ort war,
an dem die Leute
noch verrückter wurden.
Mit Bellelay verschwindet eine Welt.
Das weiss auch der zuständige
Direktor der privaten Spitalgruppe,
die die Klinik schon vor einiger Zeit
vom Kanton Bern übernommen hatte.
Natürlich habe auch ich
gemischte Gefühle.
Man hängt an so einem Ort.
Dessen Geschichte, in all
ihren Schattierungen, hat Gewicht.
Auch all das,
was hier geleistet wurde,
wie Psychiatrie vorangebracht wurde.
Natürlich verbindet man viel
mit Bellelay.
Ich denke aber, dass unser Weggang
auch erleichternd sein kann.
Die Leute können nun einfach sagen:
"Ich gehe ins Spital
für einige Zeit."
Man muss die Vergangenheit
nicht auslöschen,
aber der Psychiatrie
ein modernes Gesicht geben.
Seltsames Gefühl, nicht?
- Ja, sehr seltsam.
Seit 14 Jahren
komme ich jeden Morgen hierher.
Immer bin ich
durch diese Allee gegangen.
Jeder Baum ist
in meinem Gedächtnis gespeichert.
Ja, aber es gab hier auch
wirklich viel Leid.
Woran denkst du, meine Jojo?
An Moutier.
- An Moutier.
Super, Jojo, extra.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2023